What's going on, guys. This is Robin and little.
Do you guys know I've actually got a secondary project?
That's actually bigger than comments explaining called pop culture.
Explain like how many explained focuses on comics, pop culture,
explain focuses on everything else.
And so we're starting things off by explaining celebrities and then we'll go
into like other stuff that's more pop culture oriented and kind of expand from
there. We're basically copying the formula of comics explained, right?
Like I blew up with the channel because I was doing character explanations.
So we're doing celebrity explanations. Um,
and there were just kind of expand from there, but this is one of the,
the celebrity explanations that I've done, which is on Stan Lee.
So if you guys enjoy it, make sure you guys head over and check out the channel.
You'll find the link down in the description. Uh, and yeah,
I will catch you all later.